kings and emperors historically led
armies into battle
but as you'll know heads of state
haven't exactly done that for a while
lbj wasn't fighting in vietnam and queen
elizabeth wasn't engaged in the
falklands
but when and why did this change occur
when did king's emperors and president
stop leading their troops into battle
now there are numerous reasons why kings
and emperors would so often lead armies
in the classical and medieval periods
there was an expectance that a ruler
would also be a great general and that a
king would want to win great victories
for themselves
however the main reason was simple for
the overwhelming majority of rulers
power at this point was derived from
their armies and so giving said means to
power to someone else many of whom would
have been men of rank or even close
relatives to the ruler was not a smart
idea
now even when these kings and emperors
led their soldiers into battle they
weren't
often at the fall they would mostly
stand on a hill with a good view and
give orders
this wasn't a risk-free strategy though
and whilst rare kings did get captured
and killed
so when did things change and why well a
common idea is that king stopped leading
troops after the invention of firearms
since standing on a hill behind the
action wasn't so safe
but really that wasn't the reason since
the effective range of a musket was
pretty short and so leaders were still
safe
although when firearms did become more
accurate it certainly prevented monarchs
from coming back
in fact the declining king's leading
armies occurred in the 18th century and
by the mid-19th century the practice was
pretty much dead
for example the last british monarch to
lead troops into battle was george ii in
1743 at the battle of dettingen
in fact from this point onwards most
rulers barring napoleon the first did
very little actual leading and were
essentially mascots
and obviously there are exceptions to
all of this such as in 1934 when the
king of saudi arabia led troops into
battle against yemen
so what were the reasons for this to end
well a lot of it was due to the
professionalisation
of militaries that came about after the
30 years war this centuries-long process
saw the creation of a full-time officers
corps who were ideally promoted based
upon merit
and frankly king's presidents and
emperors weren't the best at leading
armies unless they had been military
leaders before becoming heads of state
furthermore the role of these leaders
and the political landscapes they worked
in were much more stable
george iii giving the duke of wellington
a large army wasn't a threat to his
power because succession laws were
pretty solid by this point
i mean it's not like these troops would
have declared him king after his victory
at waterloo was tended to happen in say
the roman empire and the same applied to
other rulers james madison wasn't under
threat of any military coup when
washington was sacked since the founding
values of the us government were well
respected
as the centuries progressed wars became
much greater in scale
gone were the days of a single ruler
leading one army across a country
instead it was done by a general staff
who had spent their lives as soldiers
and could understand the complexities of
war in a way that a professional rubber
stamp could not
and also culture no longer required for
a king or ruler to be a great military
leader
instead they just needed to be competent
in navigating internal politics and it's
these reasons the professionalization of
the military the expansion of war scale
and complexity the security of modern
constitutions and cultural change which
said that the ruler no longer needed to
be a warrior which saw a king's role on
the battlefield come to an end
i hope you enjoyed this episode and a
special thanks to my patrons
james bissonette the pastry section
danny maloney marvin castell kelly
moneymaker rob waterhouse john bisquez
mo james castaneda aaron the white
jordan longley marcus asner gustav swann
jerry lamdin john bailey calling
castleman rasheed ali spinning three
plates field oink oink maggie patzkowski
david silverman izzy
lexi schwinn robert wetzel skye
chappelle spencer lightfoot and winston
k
wood lizzy would have been great at it
though